we're live we're live we're live yeah
yeah all right
it's a big night in America people the
first GOP GOP debate from Milwaukee
Wisconsin I'm Dave Rubin fresh from my
Mexican vacation Off the Grid I returned
I brought Michael malice with me he's
beside me uh Glenn Greenwald and Jordan
Peterson are going to join us uh in a
few minutes the debate just ended
they're still inside we came out a
little bit early and you know it's a
serious night Michael Mouse because I'm
wearing it I know I was very impressed
no lapelpin though no well they someone
stole my Bros
uh it's a big night for I guess the
Republicans in America and the pundits
and the chattering classes and everybody
else so let's just kind of just dive
right into it uh did you see any major
winner first I want to give you the
first opening Salvo before I chime in
with any thoughts the winner tonight I
should how should I introduce you for
the people that may not know you for the
time I may not know the pride of America
I think the big winner tonight was the
Democratic establishment because if I
was a democratic establishment and
watched this kind of clown car I would
feel very confident about my chances
going in 2024 even with a weekend at
Bernie situation with the corpse of a
candidate uh I thought it was a very bad
job by the moderators I thought they did
a terrible job of holding everyone in
place people take as much space as you
give them right you and I both do this I
haven't seen debate moderation that week
since you had Candace and Blair on your
show wow but that is an old school
reference it's true but the point is
like I don't blame them a vague for
talking over everyone I don't blame Mike
Pence for talking off everyone you're
there you want as much camera time as
possible it's their job to Wrangle these
people they all signed agreements and
they were not held to them well it's
interesting about the agreements because
I've seen this repeatedly I was at the
uh the Republic another Republican I was
at the Florida gubernatorial debate the
one debate they did between DeSantis and
uh but the uh Chris Chris Chris Charlie
Chris Charlie Chris Jesus they all start
melting together when you're off the
grid it's one horrible human being yes
it is
um and they had signed an agreement
right before saying that each candidate
would not directly question another so
Christy uh Chris Chris goes up there and
starts asking to send us all these
questions and DeSantis refuses to answer
if you're watching at home and you
didn't know that they agreed to
something you'd be like boy the Santa's
got real stiff seem like a robot but if
you heard what the moderator said you
know before the TV cameras are on you
see a different version of it that's why
it was nice to be inside I thought where
I could see a little bit of the the
stuff that you don't quite get to see on
TV my main takeaway was that that there
was there was definitely no like clear
winner no not at all I say that everyone
knows my feelings about DeSantis
obviously I think he did a nice job
there was no he didn't take any major
hit but he didn't score any major win
and I think that's what people are
looking for at the moment from him and I
don't think that was there he felt like
wallpaper he seemed like he was an also
ran at one point when he was going back
with the fake he actually looks scared
for it and startled
um I thought it was a very poor night
for him because this was his moment to
be like you guys are talk I'm the one
who delivers results look at Florida
we're the model he could have turned to
Mike Pence and said there's a reason
people had Florida as the model and not
Indiana when you were governor no one
was saying let's move to Indiana he
didn't take any of these opportunities
and I thought one of the weakest moments
he had was when they're asking about
January 6 which is pertinent because
tomorrow president Trump is going to be
arrest indicted excuse arrested as a
result of this and he's like well I'm
not worried about January 6th I'm worry
about January 20th 2025 which is such a
canned line it's like this isn't just
some historical Oddity this is currently
the news right now with the front runner
uh so I know he came prepared but I
thought he was very poorly prepared yeah
so all right so I by no stretch did I
think he crushed it I think it was sort
of just like a net nothing for him which
is I think he needed more than right
that's my point yeah so I'm with you on
that uh let's talk about vivec a little
bit because Vivek right out of the gate
came out guns blazing I'm the different
guy he's very animated he looks
differently he's younger yes he's more
you know his arms are longer there's a
lot of facial reactions and little
little things from what I could tell in
there the crowd kind of liked it at the
beginning but was very tired about it in
the end I I thought the one line that
really hurt him actually was when he
said this thing you're everyone on this
stage except for me is bought and sold I
think that was roughly the quote and
everyone in the audience everyone booed
him even people that were applauding him
before like this idea that yes you are
just the non-candidic candidate everyone
else has canned lines your canned line
of saying that they have canned lines is
not a can line I thought there was
something that it struck me as he lost
momentum as it kind of went on although
he had some night him and Pence really
were like yes I ain't going to dinner
tonight I thought it was a good night
for him in the sense that a lot of
people aren't Political Animals like us
they don't know who this guy is yeah so
he did score a lot of points in terms
yeah people suddenly are like okay who's
this guy he's saying what I wanted to be
saying at the same time like you said I
feel like he came off in some ways like
a wish.com Donald Trump where it's just
like yeah we know the shtick that you're
doing and we that that but he's very
smart because as you and I discussed
earlier on your show what happens if
Trump is forced out of the race where do
those 40 of Maga voters or just ride or
die or Trump where are they going to go
yeah so he's clearly making a bid for
them I think he did a very good bit for
them and I thought it was very funny
because I thought his strongest moment
was when he really rattled your girl
Nikki Haley because she was clutching
her pearls and wagging her finger and
she seemed more like she was running for
president the PTA oh they were
representing the United States yeah it
was like what do you it was like she he
really got under her skin and I thought
that was hilarious all right so let's
talk about Nikki Haley I said to you
earlier this morning she strikes me as
the Dark Horse because she she was B she
to me would come across exactly as she
came across tonight which was she's a
functional adult you may disagree with
her on some things and agree with her on
some things but she's got I think a
fairly good track record as governor and
as un U.S ambassador to the U.N and I
thought she kind of did just that
tonight twice whether you agree or
disagree I know you I know you fully
disagree with her on on I I agree with
your assessment of her role the point is
2024 is going to be a year about
imprisoning political opponents trans
kids how much money we spend in Ukraine
responsibility is not what the
Republican electorate wants so I think
this would have made a lot of sense in
2012. if you had her versus Romney
everyone's going for her because she's
got all of Rodney's benefits of his uh
faults but in terms of the where the
Republican party in America is today
just after what happened with Covetous
and the madness there I think that she's
really out of her time so all right
let's just we'll keep just going through
everybody let's talk about Doug
or like someone won a sweepstake oh and
by the way unless you
I'm here
I thought he was actually I did not know
who this man
and now we hear from literally who
no so they bring him out and I don't
know if they showed this part on TV I
don't know if you saw everybody walk out
but you know he's got a limp because
something happened to either his leg or
his back while playing basketball
yesterday and I respect the basketball
injury I thought his answers were
actually pretty solid and he's he's
obviously like kind of a s I would say
like decent conservative but but this
thing ain't happening right right he's
like this is it he's won here's what the
mess dropped yeah when you start talking
about how great teachers are and how
they're underpaid in this country uh the
teachers union I think Republican voters
understand is one of the biggest in my
opinion they're a bigger threat to
America than China is by far what
they're doing to the kids and the
sanctimoniousness and the the absolute
depravity coming out of some of these
schools so for them be like you know we
need to support more teachers the hell
out of here that line was ironic because
they handed him the easiest exactly they
handed him the gift of oh you've done it
right you've been making the trans stuff
in North Dakota and then he's kind of
made it like oh but it's not really
happening is computer science I promise
you these kids know how to use a phone
better than any of us right okay so
let's I think we're kind of done with
him so let's go to the other guy we're
done with uh ASA Hutchinson it's just
it's just nothing it's just she looks
like this is Romero without the makeup
like video like a bad face like that
black girl I think they're too young for
that yeah it was he was very disturbing
to look at with that comb over it's just
like alternate universe Biden like do we
need another like Gravelly corpse like
you know that I thought he would he has
never Lane yeah because Trump sucks is
Chris Christie's Lane and Chris Christie
did that lane far better he took up
three lanes then ASA Hutchinson so I
think Christy actually had a pretty
decent we predicted this yeah we
predicted earlier today on your show
people don't sleep on Chris Christie uh
I thought it was really funny when
Martha uh McCallum was this close to
asking him if he was a flying saucer
because I I thought that's where she was
going with that question but he he was
aggressive but then he has a way of kind
of being very he has a way of being
aggressive and then he can suddenly like
back off and then seems like kind of
human I think his jersey attitude like
actually kind of played well I think
he's not afraid to fight clearly I
thought he had a pretty decent night he
uh let them Boo and didn't try to fight
the crowd he got his points
clearly and succinctly he had his lines
that were rehearsed but like a good
stand with comedian which you know very
well he didn't sound rehearsed he
sounded like off the top of his head he
had these good solid lines I thought it
was a great night for him
um and I I wasn't surprised it was a
great night for him even though I don't
like the man at all right okay
interesting all right and then uh Pence
is that it because everybody have a pen
sir oh no
oh god there was something interesting
going on with Pence tonight which is
that a lot of it seemed to revolve
around yes a disproportionate amount
relative to poles and everything I think
that kind of bodes well for him like he
just kind of again like I don't know
where that real support is I I think
he's kind of muddled on some stuff but
like there was something there tonight
you can't deny that I don't think sure
but I don't think it was as good as him
versus Kamala Harris where I think he
just wiped the floor with her uh I don't
see what support he picks up I think he
did good in terms of his reputation in
terms of the Republican party going
forward instead of being a pariah maybe
he'll get his Fox News slot or something
like that but I I don't think that this
is going to do much in terms of getting
him Traction in terms of the primaries
and the caucuses going forward I don't
see who is going to go if I hate Trump
or I'm not a trump person I'm going with
Christy over Mike Pence it seems like an
obvious choice right and uh and Tim
Scott thank God
I you know that that sort of whisper
half whisper like sort of preacher not
preacher again I've interviewed him I
think he is a decent man and as I I only
tweeted once during the entire uh debate
about the debate itself and I said you
know whether you agree with these guys
or not whether you like them or not like
these people they seemingly do like
America now they may not love it the
exact way that we would want them to or
something like that that's very
different than I think if you put eight
Democrats on stage now where they
fundamentally don't Tim Pence sorry Tim
Scott
was Marco Rubio dipped in chocolate he
was a complete robot there was nothing
charismatic but wow Conor just blushed
it Am I Wrong natural color in his face
am I wrong no there's nothing
charismatic about him at all there's
nothing interesting about him at all
he's the
um diversity hire for the Republican
party uh I think and he has no good
public speaking either or a resume to
speak of I think it's just uh
embarrassing that he's kind of up there
and I don't see any future for him uh
other than maybe in some cabinet for
some non-trump uh Republican president
down the road how much do you think
these things move people do you think
they really move people you know that's
always the question we can analyze them
to death and there's a few you know who
they know about it yeah you know who
they move they move the donors because
if I'm investing money in a candidate I
want this guy to be bought and paid for
I got to make sure he can go on stage
and fight for me and and get some noise
and get uh like unearned media and
things like that right so real quick it
would just go through everybody again so
DeSantis we're kind of both agreeing it
was a push it wasn't a win but the thing
is but you think that's a loss of itself
come on this was his chance to be like I
was the alternative to Trump and here's
why for months I was the alternative to
Trump here's my record he's he sounds
like a scared kid oh it's good oh my God
we've got green Walls the internet is
good enough holy cow Glenn how are you
guys
we said I was actually kind of out of
the corner of my eye trying to read what
you were writing on Twitter at poker
face
we need to share the the mic yeah okay
so so Glenn being on here guys let us
know if the mics are okay we've only got
two bikes so first off we have never
done a show together in all of these
years it's true Glenn and I Glenn and I
used to be mortal Twitter enemies we
traded a lot of enemies over various
different platforms and then we started
speaking more amicably and now here we
are together live in person and the
funny thing is I think you still roughly
consider yourself a man of the left in a
certain sense is that is that yeah I
mean I think these labels have changed a
lot right they've gone through a lot of
transformation I think a lot of our big
debates aren't even really susceptible
to that like big Tech collaborating with
the United States government to control
the internet is that a left or that is
that a right issue Horizon yeah
imperialism the war in Ukraine I think
some of these things just evade these
labels so I think they become less and
less important but I don't think I've
changed my worldview or core ideology in
any way I think a lot has changed around
me like it has for you well I only
mentioned it because regardless of
whether the labels mean anything or not
at this point it's kind of funny that
guys like you and I who let's say five
years ago would have been sitting in
debates with very different crowd were
sitting you were literally sitting
behind Marjory Taylor green we were
sitting next to Junior and Kimberly and
Matt Gates that it's like this is a
really odd sign you said to you I said
go back to 2016 and tell the Dave Reuben
of 2016. yeah yeah take a picture of
where you are and show you and I think
even you would not believe that I
certainly would not so I'll just recap
real quick what our our basic assessment
was you can clean up some of this for me
we sort of thought it was just like a
push for DeSantis and he thinks it kind
of push is sort of a loss and that there
were no major wins there but no major
losses do you think that's a sort of
fair yes I mean when you're behind by 30
to 40 points and your campaign is
struggling not collapsing but struggling
by all metrics you need something to
change course and I don't I don't think
there was a moment where he did that
probably it's the first time people are
seeing him in this setting so maybe his
com he was obviously confident there was
no failures maybe that opened up some
people's minds by far the thing that
impressed me the most and my impress I
just mean the thing that I thought was
the biggest takeaway was how much
attention was paid to Vivek he got the
entire debate to Center on him in a way
that I think was pretty remarkable given
that he's the only one up there not a
known political Commodities yeah did you
feel like some of the the gimmick
portion of it kind of worked at the
beginning and then sort of ran lost
seemed like at the beginning he's very
animated he's young you know it's like
his arms are flying a little at least he
looks different and it was kind of
working I think the one line that really
hit him I just said this to Michael this
thing about you're all bought and sold
and I'm not like that does feel a little
like come on I think the problem is is
that even for the candidates up there
who aren't doing well
in the polls and aren't likely to do
well there's still people who are
reasonably liked by Republican voters
Tim Scott Nikki Haley I don't think
there's a lot of like condemned for
these people among Republican voters and
so does yeah there should be more much
more but there's not so I did not say
like every single one of these like
Trump used to say that but would
directed it like Jeb Bush or Marco Rubio
right to say that just about everybody I
think comes off like it's kind of
arrogant it's very dismissive at the
same time you know Trump changed a lot
of the rules of how these things work
like that's something that you couldn't
say eight years ago I wonder whether
that is as offensive as we think it
might be to people did he change the
rules did he change the rules for him
right is this something where someone
else can adopt the mantle or Trump could
pull it off because it's clearly
authentic well that's right somebody's
by The End by the end of it I was sort
of feeling ah you don't have that Trump
thing like there you can do it at
moments but Trump seems like he can just
do it over over decades I I don't know I
feel like I mean for me and you know
sort of pendantry is always speculative
right but here we are to debate and this
is what you do is punditry at the end
yeah
um you know I feel like vivec is
positioning himself as at least someone
that Trump would have to consider for a
vice presidential candidate and so from
that perspective I think he's showing
enough facility with the sort of trump
approach to things and the most the most
clarifying moment was the Warner in
Ukraine where he was really the only one
adamantly saying this is not a word we
should be fighting using the Trump
populism of 2016. why are we spending
money on foreign words when we are can't
even protect our own border that's
something I think is going to resonate
with those kind of Voters and I think he
was pretty authentic about it I mean
I've interviewed him on that that is
clearly his position how do you gauge so
I think the three of us are PR you know
I I don't fully consider myself in
isolationists are pretty yeah yeah we'll
get that in a sec but on the on the on
the Vivek sub with the war like I think
the three of those are pretty anti-war
certainly right so
think that most Americans are though
because you know Pence got a lot of
Applause on Ukraine stuff Nikki got some
Applause on Ukraine from Republican
voters though yeah but this is a
republican Prime yeah yeah this is a
Republican primary
you gauge how far and policy matters
well there was this new Pole right which
is ultimately the most effective way I
think Michael's right I mean one of the
things I noticed is my first Republican
debate is you know the seats in the
middle are all Republican RNC don't you
know Trump pointed that out in 2016 when
he was getting booed for criticizing
jobs
these are all their lobbyists and donors
which is actually exactly how it happens
this is not representative public
opinion probably makes a difference on
TV because you don't really realize that
at the same time pulling data there was
a new CNN poll showing that the majority
of Americans now oppose sending more
money to Ukraine and the only reason it
was even as close as it was 55 45 is
because 75 of self-identified liberal
Democrats support sending that money to
Ukraine so the Republican Party public
opinion is aggressively eroding on these
questions yeah and I just don't think
there's an appetite at all for sending
more money to Ukraine so what do you
think Pence angle on this is and then
we'll get to Christy when Pence is like
but we have to arm them because if we
don't arm them they're on their way to
Belarus I'm shocked that Pence basically
invoke Domino policy which was the
reason we were in Vietnam because
literally if we don't stop them in
Vietnam then they're going to Laos and
they're going to Cambodia they're coming
out to Washington they're coming to
Oklahoma and that literally I forgot who
was who said that if we don't stop them
in Ukraine we're next and that's crazy
and that's complex
Nikki or Chris Christie you know it was
just like guys it doesn't go Russia
Ukraine United States even or even
Russia Ukraine Paris right yeah you got
to get through a couple others
if the point they're trying to make
trying to steal me on their argument
they're like okay after Ukraine it gets
to Nato well that's just an argument
maybe we shouldn't be in NATO not well
we're a NATO so we're gonna have to send
boots on the ground to Germany right
which would be a trump argument by the
way so we both agreed that Christy
actually had a pretty good night that he
pushed himself in he's a he's a big
presence literally and figuratively he
was kind of funny at moments he's
aggressive and then and then oddly kind
of pleasant like what do you make him
I mean I I think that what the polling
is showing is the Republican Party
adores Donald Trump like there's no
getting around that right so if you not
all of them obviously but
the biggest chunk of Republican party uh
voters still really really like Donald
Trump and if you're presenting yourself
as the anti-trump candidate which Chris
Christie clearly is going on ABC and CNN
for no reason other than to bastrump and
saying he's below the Dignity of the
America you know that is something that
I think is just going to turn Republican
vote I mean DeSantis you notice is very
careful
you know never to really say even that
Trump's guilty his Focus every time he's
asked is on the corruption and
weaponization of the Biden just
Department he doesn't want to alienate
Trump voters because I think he knows
that he
can't get the nomination if he does
whereas Chris Christie is there just to
pass Trump for whatever motives Chris
Christie has in doing that yeah but
here's the thing I think the mega voters
are very very suspicious of anyone who's
at any way being like playing both sides
of the fence about Trump so when
DeSantis is playing koi they don't trust
him for one New York minute so I think
that plays very poorly against him he's
trying to play it safe but you can't
play it safe when the base wants blood
and the base does seem to want to blood
so let's talk about Trump a little bit I
mean he wasn't here today what do you
think about him not being here again I I
didn't know he wasn't going to be here
until until malice told me a couple
hours ago and frankly it's like it's
hard to make of what we just watched
because the main guy wasn't there as
they pointed out yeah I mean it was it
was a it was a debate in the parallel
universe where Donald Trump's not
running right
um look I'm somebody who as a journalist
and somebody who thinks people running
for president have a responsibility they
respect you know the voters I think he
should be here I think if you're going
to run for president you should
participate in debates
that said it just is a long-standing
role of American politics that if you
have a gigantic lead you don't raise the
Elevate you know you don't Elevate the
stature of your opponent's trailing Far
Behind by debating them
um it's a strategic calculation it's a
political calculation therefore it's not
one that I love I wish you were here but
I kind of get why he's not and and it's
also a legal calculation because if he's
on stage being asked questions about all
his indictments which he would certainly
have to be asked he's in a position
where if he's saying things publicly
that screw up his legal cases this could
have criminal ramifications any lawyer
will tell you when you're involved in a
legal case you do not discuss a public
and let your lawyers do it you are not a
fan of the weaponization of government
to say the least it looks like Trump is
so he's going to be indicted well I
guess he's been indicted and now he's
arrested arrested tomorrow
um do you put this at the top right now
of all of the important issues I think
it's unbelievable that every time I'm a
country we regard as an adversary
country sometimes even ones we regard as
allies
start indicting and criminalizing
political opponents we instantly see
that as a Hallmark of tyranny yes you
know I got when I one of the main issues
that I had when I first started writing
about politics and the early war on
terror was I thought that a lot of bush
Cheney officials and even CIA officials
Auto even prosecuted for war on terror
crimes for torture for rendition for
illegal leaves dropping with no warrants
and the consensus and the political
media class was we don't do that that's
what banana republics do I wrote a book
saying actually banana republics there's
two a two-tiered system of law where
Elites are exempt and don't get
prosecuted
the problem is I'd be cheering if we
were really abandoning this two tiered
uh system of justice where where
political leaders are exempt of course
though we're not it's a one-time only
exemption for Trump it's totally
politically motivated
I'd be cheering prosecution of trump if
he had committed classic crimes like
murder or extortion or bribery or you
know kidnapping or just the kind of Casa
corruption that politicians should go to
jail for none of that
that he's being indicted for is that
these are all like dubious
interpretations of the law do you think
even if he did do some things that were
illegal or or you know with classified
arguments or talking about them like if
there are some things let's say on the
margins that he did that are legal would
you still make the argument because I
kind of would that you still have to let
him off because otherwise we end up in
Banana Republic regardless here's the
the main issue for me so if you ask me
just from a lawyer perspective which of
the four cases are the strongest I would
easily say the mar-a-logger case of the
classified documents just because that
doesn't actually require this dubious
interpretation of the law but thing is
every single day I mean literally every
day if you pick up the New York Times
The Washington Post you will read people
leaking classes that is the game they
play every single day so you turn on the
TV and you see these people these panels
expressing indignation that he was
careless in the maintenance of class
these people are playing games with
classified information every single way
more sensitive than the ones he's
Accused by the way not of leaking but of
improperly maintaining and when you add
on to that the fact that everyone agrees
as president he had the unilateral and
unreviewable power to declassify them
ultimately their whole case comes down
to and again this is the strongest one
nothing more than just kind of like a
bureaucratic oversight that like he kind
of forgot or failed to declassify those
documents prior to taking them if that's
the thing on what you're staking the
prosecution of the leading oppositional
figure in the United States I don't
really care whether he did it or not
that is Way Beyond what uh is a
tolerable use of the police power yeah I
accept that argument I think I'm more of
a leftist than Glenn I Believe In
fairness I believe in equality I am for
the arrest of all current living
presidents and vice presidents and I
think we should exhume a bunch of them
Lincoln too and put him on trial we'll
give him habeas corpus we'll have the
actual corpse we know where it is well
that's the gnome Chomsky argument the
famous one that if we have ever even
applied just the Nuremberg principle
exactly let alone American domestic law
every American president of the
post-world War II era would be
prosecuted hung up the egg well maybe on
Rumble but yeah no on Rumble you can say
whatever you want exactly
you can't say that in there
not a moderate so I can agreed to
compromise regarding where it is so it
doesn't have to be a Hague every time
you say something controversial suddenly
he becomes a moderate
than I am and then 10 seconds later he
was a moderate so it's very confusing
malice do you have anything to say about
some of the lesser-known people say the
ASA Hutchinson's or Doug with the badge
I mean we were talking about this like
we do politics for a living right like
we paid taxes
I honestly I still can't I don't know
his last name I'm happy you know I'm
sure being our governor of North Dakota
is a perfectly fine thing to be he's
like how do you contrast yourself
right now oh here comes Jamie we got
Jordan Peterson this is about to get
ready officially in the IDW now yeah
here we go all right Jordan talking
about improbable panels yeah this is
this is the most improbable panel of all
time Jordan you can even you can take
your uh your thing off your oh yeah yeah
you know I can't read like the fact that
they make you a ball baby you walk in
there you were the biggest star in the
whole room I'm really impressed that
they had that suit at Macy's for you
yeah what a lucky coincidence the only
one who got more attention than Vivek
tonight was was Jordan uh JP what what
did you make of what you did first off
what are you doing here I didn't even
know you were here and then someone said
they saw you having dinner
someone I know who has transportation
for making this sort of thing very
straightforward and so we had the
opportunity to tell me and I had the
opportunity to come down and why the
hell not come down you know I mean it's
and if
stunningly interesting anthropological
Endeavor for a Canadian right I mean so
it's great theater and I've interviewed
a lot of the candidates now and so I
know them a little bit and I was
fascinated to see how they would all
perform what do you think of Doug
what did I think it Doug I don't know I
you know I thought actually all things
considered and maybe it's because Canada
sets such a low bar on this front I
thought that the entire slate of
candidates was really quite markedly
credible you know they're wow I think
all of them landed at least one blow I
don't think any of them made
the sort of mistake that would make you
cringe and make you think they were
clearly unfit for the job
it was a tough debate because there's
eight people and you don't have a lot of
time to develop your arguments and so
you know I thought
I could have been far less impressed
with the whole Endeavor than I was yeah
you know why are you impressed
yeah was there anything that that kind
of moved you or moved you on anyone
specifically and yeah you've you've
interviewed pretty much humor
I like that I think he's nicer he has a
nicer Persona than anybody can possibly
be and I think that that's probably
actually harming him there's not enough
Shadow there I don't think
um meaning that it comes off as
inauthentic like yeah
it's it's
it it
lacks it's like elevator music you know
it lacks it lacks gravitas and so and
and he may he may figure that out what
did you make of it back because I mean
for me like the debate the thing that
was most surprising was so much he was
able to draw all the attention to him
despite being the least kind of you know
politically established figure in that
stage it was quite an accomplishment
yeah well it was his ability to
generate both positive and negative
emotions in excess was quite on display
because I think he had the most positive
and the most negative responses right so
he had the most variability and I
suppose that's part of Charisma right I
would say
he's clearly bright I think that some of
the things he did
exemplified the utility of his
youthfulness
and there is some use in that now
because the world's changing so quickly
that being somewhat younger at least in
principle could be advantageous he
didn't use pause as well he's kind of
impulsive you know
um I don't think the insults he levied
against the other candidates I don't
think any of them helped him what do you
think specifically of the line where he
said I'm the only one on the stage who's
not bought and so I thought I thought
that was the one that that yeah well I
think well I think that was the I think
that was the that was the worst element
of his performance was that line and it
was unfortunate to me because
the reason he said that at least in part
is because he has concentrated on a
spending his own money and B Gathering a
multitude of tiny donations from very
many people so he's not beholden to
Super Pacs let's say and I think he
could have explained that to people yeah
instead of using what was essentially a
cheap shot it's the what made it a cheap
shot was you can't insult seven people
at the same time with the same insult
right it's not targeted yeah and I don't
that's the only time when you got here
was Trump would say very similar things
I'm the only one not bad paid for it but
he would direct it to Jeb Bush or he
would direct it at Marco Rubio like
every one of those people on that stage
has some degree of affection among
Republican voters right right yeah so
when you're just condemning all of them
at once you're gonna offend somebody
yeah I also don't think it did him any
good like yeah I don't think the
audience responded to it well and I also
don't think that there's no reason for
any of the Republican candidates to make
enemies out of the people they're
running against any more than is
absolutely necessary because as you said
they all have a constituency they're all
in the same boat and you know if you
could land a criticism and it furthered
your case
then fine but my sense of in in watching
Vivek was that the the insults were not
they also highlighted his youthfulness
in a way that was negative because it
wasn't there was an element of it that
was um
yes yes
it's where that degenerated into sort of
like a high school debate what did you
think the one moment I would give him
credit for with that is it really seemed
that he got under Nikki Haley's skin and
I thought she came off very peevish when
she was trying to counter and wagging
her finger in his face yeah well
yeah and
there's lots
lots and certainly defend himself I I
just don't think that his descent into
the realm of insult I don't think it did
I don't think there was anything in it
that was positive yeah so I think he
should just stop doing that and I think
that I thought I thought DeSantis came
across very credibly yeah his
performance didn't have a lot of Highs
but it didn't have any lows it was sort
of a flat line yeah but but a reasonably
a reasonably
are reasonably what would you call it
competent Flat Line yeah but again and
he got going pretty good on the southern
border defense I said to malice that I
thought and you know how I feel about
this I said that it for me it was
basically a push that there was no major
win but but nobody hit him on anything
yeah right right that was kind of kind
of decent on his side but I want to ask
you about about Trump for a sec because
you had a line with um with Piers Morgan
about a year ago where he was asking you
about whether Trump should run or not
and you said that in essence and you can
correct me wrong but in essence it was
that we have to have this out publicly
yeah because otherwise there will be two
that's part of the problem criminal
prosecution
yeah right well you know and I also
think that's terribly off brand and I
think the same I don't think it's off
brand with Biden but I think it's the
same kind of mistake it's like
come and stomp your opponents show
people you can do it now I think what he
did tonight in some ways given that he
didn't show up at the debate was
brilliant strategically to go talk to
talker tonight at the same time it's
like it's starting five minutes
but but I think in a democracy that was
fully functioning properly Biden would
be debating and so would Trump and I
think that that's a a mark of respect
for the process and for the American
people but it's also a mark of
confidence you know it's and so and and
Trump might be thinking well I only have
something to lose but I don't think that
that defensive strategy is the most
appropriate strategy for someone who
actually wants to be a leader but I was
making the point earlier I think a lot
of this has to be the legal strategy
because if he's going to be asked about
his cases he can't just plead the fifth
on that on that debate stage and he has
a big problem of opening his mouth and
making things worse from Legally
possibly yeah well you know I I don't
know what precautions he's taking in
relationship to his legal battle he's
not really renowned renowned for taking
a lot of precautions yeah yeah well but
that's also partly why oh
Trump I think all the candidates States
so you saw very frequently when the
discussion wandered into Trump territory
especially if it was critical of trump
that the audience would respond quite
negatively and that's interesting
because most of the people here
obviously aren't so enamored with Trump
that they won't come to the debate sure
but you see that fracture and I don't
think any of the candidates really
capitalized on that disaffectation among
the working class in particular on
economic and Status front that Trump
manages none of them capitalized on that
energy and and I think that's and that
was also true of Vivek right and and
that's a none of them did that and
that's that's definitely a lack because
Trump's a master at that they're working
Democrats yeah they were just money on
the table for them yeah yeah yeah I
asked Glenn this when he sat down and
Glenn and I used to be hardcore enemies
on Twitter for years fighting with each
other and you know he was always getting
into it with Sam Harris and all that
stuff do you find it odd that you're at
a republican debate and you know
my life
really you got as big Applause as anyone
in that room that was on that stage
sitting with Glenn and the anarchists
over here and we've been doing our thing
for years but like what an odd
collection of people that are trying to
make sense and whatever whether we're
right or wrong about any of the stuff
we're talking about this is far more
closer to the truth than anything that's
on CNN or MSNBC or these other places
right yeah yeah well and you can you
know you can see this you can see this
really starting to have a profound
effect I mean
um DeSantis people reached out to me
today so they'll be on my podcast soon I
talked to Chris Christie I talk to Mike
Pence you know I've interviewed a large
number of the candidates and I'll
probably interview well all the rest of
them who want to but Doug yeah when you
talk to Doug yeah well we'll see
yeah yeah yeah
can I borrow the car we'll see the
positive side of that is that the
podcasts it's very difficult it's very
difficult to falsify a podcast I think
and Rogan's talked about this too if you
bring someone in and you run them out
for two hours
first of all you see if there's enough
there to talk for two hours and you
can't you can't really be a persona for
two hours not especially not on YouTube
people figure that out real quick and so
I think we could see a real
shift in
pull it in in the public conception of
politicians but also politicians
conceptions of the public because part
of the reason that politicians have come
to believe that the public is stupid and
has no attention span is that television
had a 30-second attention span so you
know you had to assume your audience
remembered nothing knew nothing and
could flip out to a different Channel at
any moment plus the bandwidth was
insanely expensive now all that's gone
so I think that'll I think that'll be a
revolution in in political discourse I
was talking about this with Dave earlier
it was a huge unforced error for the uh
of the Santos campaign to not be making
the rounds of podcasts because it was
like monkey pox he was everywhere yeah
he was doing every podcast answering
questions without canned answers coming
off like hey I'm talking to your
different audiences and P you know one
of the big things about New Hampshire
and Iowa used to be I want to shake the
guy's hand was that like 50 of people
who meet the candidate end of the
program so that personal contact is not
a personal podcast is one to be removed
that really did well for him with
getting with the Republicans
that that
Fallen to some degree into the hands of
professional political consult ants all
those people live 1990. exactly you know
and so I mean because if you I mean of
course like 10 years ago no serious
politician would go on podcasts yeah now
there's a huge number of Voters arguably
majority who do not trust the people who
you go and speak with if you go on cable
news or if you go on network news they
trust the people who have podcasts the
audience sizes are comparable and if
you're unwilling to subject yourself to
that it seems like you said or take
advantage of it because I Ron stands is
a very smart guy he's here because
someone who I think would be would
thrive in those kinds of settings but if
you're only willing to confine yourself
to the precincts of traditional
politicians people are going to start to
think that you are one of those and I
think that's been one of the mistakes
yeah I think well look he did not that
I'm his Defender but I think he's come
around on some of this stuff he did
wrestle brand he did Megan Kelly he's
going to do your show have you have you
yeah
all right so I think I think some of
that will change on the mainstream media
part of this and just watch watching
like when you're in there and it how old
the whole thing feels yes the commercial
breaks yeah the the we're gonna ding the
bet the sound of the ding I was like
what year is this the raising of the
hands which like to say this experience
which I thought was one of his better
moments because I think people do hate
these kind of formats oh so you think
that was a better moment for him because
the crowd kind of groaned as if he
looked around yeah but he more so was
dismissing picking fights with media
even Fox News Now among conservative
voters which you know is it used to be
kind of heretical and now has become a
lot more acceptable is always a winning
strategy I mean there you look at
pulling down there's nobody no
institution that is held in Greater
contempt than media yeah that is just
the reality I mean maybe pedophiles if
you attack yeah it's a little more
popular exactly but
um there's it you know fighting with
media or you're a very bad in their
format is a no lose situation I thought
I actually thought that was a good and
it is true like you you ask a serious
question about climate or you know
um fossil fuels and the only way that
you're supposed to answer is by raising
your hand or not as you said we're not
school children let's have that debate
or not have it I thought that was
actually a good moment yeah I thought so
too and I think the point was well taken
I thought the the hand raising was
Juvenile and he won they they said okay
they they did end up talking about it as
well so did you guys think it was funny
that at the beginning of the debate and
again I don't know if this was heard on
television they said to everyone in the
audience don't yell don't cheer don't
offend but from the second it started it
just happens and then that does change
the way people at home start feeling
about it if Chris Christie was making a
perfectly reasonable point then he can't
get his next sentence out because he's
getting boobed overwhelmingly that's
going to read differently to people you
know human beings are still animals
you pick up cues from those around you
Jordan when the crowd the crowd is part
of the phenomenon yeah yeah right I mean
the integral part what do you think of
Christy because malice and I both kind
of thought I thought he had a pretty
good night I thought he kind of he's
aggressive when he needs to be yeah
you know what I noticed that when I when
I yeah
I think they call that the radius yeah
everyone tries
it's not easy to avoid Chris Christie
let me assure you guys but I thought
about yeah I thought and and Christy was
also he was also generous in
relationship to Pence and that was a
good moment on his part you know and I
also thought that that was something
that that would have showed an
additional level of maturity in Vivek if
he had been gracious at some point to
his opponents at a few of them you know
to give the devil is due because I think
if you're confident
then you can you can distribute some
credit so and you know and he may well
figure these things out because it's
very early in the campaign and and he
doesn't have the experience that the
other candidates have uh since we are
here in America doing a debate I I would
be remiss if I didn't ask you about
what's going on up in Canada because you
are in the midst of a fiasco that I have
told you many times you must move to
Florida enough is enough Texas yeah uh
yeah you want to just recap a little bit
of what's going on with you in Canada
right now committed the unforgivable sin
of uh opposing trans Butchery for
example right which I regard as a crime
against humanity because that's what
forced sterilization is and surgery on
minors that castrates them for example
that's forced sterilization and so one
of the tweets that I was pilloried for
kicked off Twitter was a tweet directed
at
um Elliot page or Ellen Page Ellen Page
yeah yes and um
the someone complained about that to the
College of psychologists and although
they do not have to pursue complaints if
they're vexatious they decided they
would pursue that and 13 others seven of
which they dropped and
um all of them are political it's so
interesting to see this it's it's
fascinating first of all they were
levied by people who claimed falsely to
be clients of mine which they weren't in
writing but more importantly oh my God
two criticisms of Trudeau one criticism
of his chief of staff one criticism of a
city councilor in Ottawa the entire
transcript of my discussion with Joe
Rogan focusing mostly the CR the
complaint was focusing mostly on the
fact that I think the climate change
fear-mongers are tyrannical
authoritarians and that almost
everything they say is not only false
even Greta even well maybe not threat
because she's such a wonderful girl
she's also Selective mute so she doesn't
say that yeah yeah yeah well and she's
obviously one of the world's leading
Authorities on the Nexus between the
energy environment and the you don't
want to engage her on the marriage yeah
giving her back scientific expertise so
so these are obviously these are clearly
political opinions clearly political
opinions and the charges that I brought
the profession of psychology into
disgrace essentially that I've conducted
myself unprofessionally
um the fact that
10 million people have bought my books
and have regarded them as helpful seems
to be absolutely Irrelevant in contrast
to the fact that six people in six years
have complained about me and uh well
it's not really relevant in the sense
it's probably the motive it's probably
the most relevant at the end of the day
like your impact is the reason yeah yeah
exactly they regard you as the danger I
just want to ask you though you know I S
we've hear so many of these stories now
and every time I listen to them I try
very hard not to lose sight of just how
shocking it is like how often now there
are cases of people being
officially persecuted by the states
for Pure political speech well this is
you predicted this the first time on my
show 2017. Absolutely inevitable yeah
yeah definitely definitely yeah
though it's been going on I remember you
know back in the day like 2009 2010 when
I was very much Associated on the left
there was that case of Ezra Lavon and
the other with Mark Stein where they
were both brought up on administrative
charges under the human rights law I
defended yeah that's right and they were
surprised but you know that was always
part of my world view is it but you
could see it coming and that was
definitely a canary Nicole yeah
absolutely just completely now
unraveling everywhere in the Democratic
world I live in Brazil where yeah it's
they they're destroying people's lives
they're preventing them from going on
the internet people who make their
living as podcasters and there's no
pretense any longer that it's because of
anything but political views it's
becoming increasingly explicit that hate
speech and misinformation is being
dispensed with this these people have
ideas that are dangerous and
destabilized into society and therefore
we can't allow them and the public
opinion in support of this is really
alarming I mean there's no public I'm
not none but not a lot
Canadians the thing about Canadians is
that for about 175 years we could take
for granted the fundamental Integrity of
our institutions so when I
for in for most of my life
the Socialists were a labor party and
they were all Union guys you know so you
know they had something to say they were
Union guys the Liberals were centrists
and they played the left and the right
and took the best ideas from both and
generally governed the conservatives
were the party of big business everyone
knew that and essentially everybody
played that game well
the education system worked reasonably
well at least it wasn't corrupt both the
public education system and the higher
education system my Canada is a pretty
damn functional country even the CBC was
fundamentally the same kind of credible
news source that the BBC was you know 15
years ago and all of that's inverted and
the same is the case of the Judiciary
and Canadians
think about what they're being asked to
swallow
either someone like me knows what the
hell is going on
or
no either someone like me is wrong or
all of the institutions in Canada have
become dangerously corrupt well who the
hell is going to bring I believe the
second one right you know you need
overwhelming evidence what do you think
is the precipitating event that caused
that transformation you were just
describing these fundamentally
trustworthy institutions probably did
some things wrong fundamentally though
as you said benevolent Fair predictable
what what do you think caused this this
kind of spiraling away from that
legitimacy
while the universities had a lot to do
with it
you know the dissemination of truly
pathological
post-modern slash
I call them neo-marxas but they're worse
than Marxist ideas you know the marxists
were only they're always obsessing about
economics economics well now it's
inequality on every Dimension you can
possibly imagine it's like metamorxism
and so I think the universities bear a
huge responsibility for this a huge
response don't you think also the
internet and the free flow of
information is a huge threat to their
power because if you have to defend your
ideas in a free market of of discourse
and so on and so forth if you're
building an empire based on lies as soon
as I catch you in one two three lies
so they have to kind of double down to
maintain their hegemony well some of
that some of that's obviously the case
in relationship to how the Legacy Media
has degenerated because part of the
reason they degenerate is like well how
can they not degenerate how can you
compete with YouTube Right YouTube is
free and billions of people are its
audience
game over on the network side obviously
because you can't compete with that and
then the networks start losing their
good people especially they're great
people and once you lose your great
people well you have mediocre people and
then the mediocre people get more
desperate and then they lose their they
lose their editorial staff and they lose
their foreign correspondence and then
they devolve to click bait and you know
part of that's just technological
transformation and so you add that to
the warping of the educational
institutions and I would also say you
know that the social media landscape
does facilitate
public discourse in a remarkable way I
think that's especially true of video
forums like like YouTube and Rumble but
it also
facilitates the divisive psychopaths in
a way that normal discourse doesn't
you're looking at me when you say no I
happen to be looking forward
yeah but well and I really think this is
a problem because
there's a small number of people who
attempt to induce chaos three percent of
the population and we have mechanisms to
protect ourselves against them in
face-to-face discourse but they're
absolutely disinhibited online and then
there's nothing you can do about it yeah
yeah those type of people you bet you
bet and there's a psychologists the
cluster B people yes exactly and well in
worse than cluster B I mean they're dark
tetrad types Machiavellian
Machiavellian narcissistic Psychopathic
and because that wasn't enough they
added sadistic right and so and that the
online troll types for example
um are much more disproportionately
likely to manifest those personality
traits and that's not good and of course
Justice though too it's like mob Justice
brings out the worst of human instincts
right I mean like once you join a mob
and that frenzy gives you that sense of
righteousness there are no limits when
no one can hold you accountable yeah
exactly and I wonder what you make
though too of I for me I think like one
of the accelerants for sure was the
Summer where first you had the British
people rejecting what they were told to
do and leaving the European Union with
brexit very closely followed by the
shocking election of trump in shocking
in every way experts said it wouldn't
happen you know everything no I don't
think credible yeah
you have no right to vote for this guy
yeah everyone agrees exactly and I think
at the end of that there was a decision
we can no longer Trust
westerners with the freedom that the
internet has been given that we've been
given them and that I think was when the
Crackdown really but they're right from
their perspective persuasive no they I
don't I think they made a rational
judgment that things were spiraling out
of their control and they needed to
regain it that's what establishments do
100 percent
well guys Glenn you've got to do your
show right do you have a show that I
have to do as well Dave I decided to
give you my premium time right now I
appreciate that Jordan are you uh
heading back out on tour what are you
what are you doing now well I'm up now
in Northern Alberta finishing up my next
book which is coming along
it's gonna be a bomb Dave yeah I'm
telling you it's gonna be an explosion
I need an explosion I could have turned
I could have actually freeze that bit
yeah yeah now you're gonna be in more
trouble with the Canadians
wait but just to cap that though so
where so where is this all at are you
you're gonna have to be done in a month
yeah and I should publish it in February
I think it's about the planet yeah no no
I meant what's going on with you in the
Canadian government I mean well the next
thing they have to do apparently and
will do now is they'll take me in front
of they're going to put me a show trial
no no uh it's worse than that it's
forestry education
I have to take courses with a social
media expert and you have to pay for it
yourself yes of an indefinite term wait
wait until I've learned this Jordan
Peterson is going to be taught how to
use social media buy a social media yeah
yeah it is shot I'm saying these things
should be this is already in place this
isn't going to this isn't potential this
will be their next you can teach the
course in trolling we'll make it happen
yeah I'm Gonna Save this country yeah so
I told them already and I will do this
I'll broadcast every bloody one of those
sessions
I will gladly rebroadcast them yeah I
have no doubt that yeah it's great I
mean it's so Preposterous social media
expert hey just exactly what the hell is
that I kind of want to sit down with you
and Coach you a bit how to drive this
person to just complete distraction
until they're slitting the wrists I'm
good at that you do know he was a
psychologist yeah but he's not a status
Machiavelli that's the difference
it was a pleasure out of all of the post
game shows that are happening across the
internet and across television this has
got to be the four strangest comments I
had the most unlikely panel discussion
that we have it's true and the two
starkest choices in suits right next to
each other I know I feel very fashioned
backwards sitting next to Jordan there
you go and for you guys although I've
been off the grid I am back officially
on September 5th brand new studio a
couple big announcements coming thanks
for watching